i want to try whole30 myself for the
next month hey guys welcome to another
diet review you've seen me cover
intermittent fasting keto well now it's
time for me to cover another incredibly
popular diet this time we're taking on
whole30 are you ready
[Music]
many people call this a diet and i feel
that's like somewhat of a misnomer i
think it should be called the whole30
challenge or a whole30 reset because
what it does is it eliminates certain
food groups very strictly for the first
30 days and then allows you to gradually
reintroduce them back into your diet and
see how they affect your body
there are eight hearted fast rules that
you have to follow religiously during
whole30. if you break one of these rules
and slip up you have to restart the
30-day cycle because as the founders
describe in their book it's not just a
reset of the diet that you eat it's an
elimination diet and if you reintroduce
one of those foods in prematurely that's
going to skew the results and you won't
learn as much from the 30 day period
don't consume any added sugars or
sweeteners artificial or otherwise do
not consume alcohol in any form do not
eat grains this includes wheat rye
barley oats corn rice quinoa and
buckwheat do not eat legumes this
includes beans of all kinds peas
chickpeas lentils and peanuts this also
includes all forms of soy soy sauce miso
tofu tempeh no go on dairy this includes
cows goats or sheep's milk products such
as milk cream cheese kefir yogurt sour
cream ice cream and frozen yogurt the
only exceptions are clarified butter or
ghee no consumption of carrageenan
sulfites or msg do not try and recreate
baked goods treats or junk foods with
approved ingredients you can't weigh
yourself or take measurements of any
kind this means no calorie counting as
well
while there are claims of improved
athletic performance sleep fat loss
improved cognition decreased food
cravings the majority of the claims
really center around the fact that
you're going to have an improved
relationship with food that you'll have
a higher understanding of how food
affects your body what works what
doesn't and because of that you're
ultimately going to be a healthier
person i thought it would be beneficial
to do what i like about whole30 and then
state my concerns and after that i'll
give you an overall guidance on what i
would recommend to a patient generally
speaking if they're sitting in front of
me
my favorite thing about whole30 is that
it absolutely makes you swear off sugary
over-processed junk food now if you
watch any piece of my content this is
the first piece of advice i give to
anybody because if you can eliminate
that alone you're going to see
tremendous health benefits and if i'm
going to give a little spoiler here i
think a lot of the benefits of whole30
come from just eliminating that it
certainly can help with weight loss
because if you're going to go on an
elimination diet where you're taking
foods out especially foods that are
quite unhealthy and contribute to
obesity odds are you're going to be
losing weight as a result it puts a
focus on real and whole foods because
oftentimes when we're dieting we're
trying to find shortcuts and ways that
we can still eat foods that are
unhealthy and over processed this really
makes you focus and eat vegetables
plant-based foods and that seems to be
at the core of whole30 i love that it
takes the focus away from weighing
yourself every single day i have too
many patients that get over zeroed in on
these numbers and forget that eating
well is not just about losing weight but
it's also about being healthy and if we
get too focused on the numbers we can
oftentimes neglect other factors of our
diets that can contribute to health
problems it can increase consumer
competency what i mean is that you're
going to be more aware of what
ingredients are found in your foods for
example many people don't know that
sugar is found in ketchup therefore
ketchup is not a whole30 approved food
knowing those little insights and
tidbits can go a long way even if you
don't follow whole30 for the rest of
your life it can change your eating
habits for the better by increasing
awareness of how food integrates into
your lifestyle for example if you're
coming home every night and you're
having two glasses of wine to decompress
after doing whole30 you may find a
different maybe even a healthier
alternative way to decompress without
needing alcohol in addition it can
highlight how certain food choices can
affect your cravings it's that gut brain
connection we sometimes talk about where
if you eat a lot of sugary foods it's
actually going to encourage you to eat
more of that there's actually a great
study that i covered on my youtube
channel about how processed foods can
affect the amount of calories you take
in throughout the day that's definitely
going to be dropped down below in my
description so check that one out
here's my first and main concern with
whole30. i think it puts an overemphasis
on anecdotal evidence of people who've
had tremendous success with the whole30
platform the next 30 days will change
your life they will change the way you
think about food they will change your
taste it will change your habits and
your cravings it will restore a healthy
emotional relationship with food and
with your body the physical benefits of
whole30 are profound a full 96 of
participants lose weight and improve
their body composition without counting
or restricting calories also commonly
reported consistently high energy levels
better sleep improved focus mental
clarity and a return to a healthy
digestive system improved athletic
performance and a sunnier disposition i
no way doubt that there were these
benefits and some of the people that
have done whole30 to make this promise
that this is going to happen to almost
everybody that does it i don't like over
promising results to my patients because
i think that ultimately provides them a
disservice it makes them believe that
this is the miracle cure-all thing that
they've been waiting for and in some
cases it may be true someone who's been
eating junk food their whole life has a
disordered digestive system because
they've been eating this junk
this can help and this can change their
life but to make it seem like no matter
who you are this is going to change your
life i think that's a bit of an
overstatement as a practicing physician
i know that patients who are suffering
with diseases are really susceptible to
any kind of marketing hype that's
promising them a cure for their
illnesses on the cover of this book it
says more significant many people have
reported the magical elimination of a
variety of symptoms diseases and
conditions in just 30 days and they go
on to list a whole host of conditions
including eczema psoriasis chronic
fatigue asthma sinus infections
allergies migraines acid reflux crohn's
celiacs ibs bipolar disorder depression
lyme disease endometriosis pcos and even
autism they don't outright state that
whole30 is the cure for any of these
conditions because then they would be in
legal trouble the fact that they're even
conflating the possibility that whole30
can be a treatment for autism or cure
for autism i think a borderline is a
little bit ridiculous and again is doing
a disservice to our patients what i
think is quite interesting is that some
of the symptoms that a whole30 aims to
remove can actually be caused by a
nutritional deficiency and whole30 on
its own can exacerbate some of these
nutritional deficiencies for example
imagine i have a patient who's
chronically fatigued and having
difficulty with energy levels and sleep
so on so forth and i find that they're
vitamin d deficient that they have a
very low vitamin d level now eliminating
all types of dairy will certainly
exacerbate that condition but had i not
run these tests beforehand and the
patient went on whole30 without
consulting me first think about the
negative outcomes that could have
occurred putting junk and processed
foods aside for a moment the foods that
you're eliminating while on whole30 can
be problematic to some people but for
most eliminating them will yield no
benefit and actually some cases can fuel
nutritional deficiencies or even
exacerbate medical problems something
else that's problematic is that whole30
tries very hard to be a proper
elimination diet which is the gold
standard that doctors use in trying to
identify food sensitivities but while it
comes close it's not exactly accurate
for example if we're going to do a
restrictive diet of any sort we would do
it for 90 days because that's how long
it takes for the immune system to sort
of shut down its response on top of that
i rarely jump to saying let's eliminate
everything and see what sticks it's kind
of a shotgun approach that may work in
some instances but may also make my
patients life so much more problematic
than it needs to be and in their
reintroduction protocol within the book
they say to introduce foods every two
three days but then they go on to say to
contradict themselves that you may have
a negative reaction a week later so at
that point you've already introduced
three foods how do you know which one is
causing a negative reaction it really
becomes problematic that this is not
done in a systemic way like we would do
in a medical setting and finally i'm not
a huge fan of restrictive diets like
this because generally they don't have
long-term success rates and i fear that
there could be psychological problems
that develop when you say to yourself
you absolutely can't have a single
cookie or you're a failure i mean that
sort of anxiety is not good for anybody
especially those who are prone to
disordered eating
so what's my overall take on this whole
30 challenge i think it's quite
interesting i think it's cool to be able
to give yourself a test of willpower for
30 days i am the main proponent of
removing junk food processed foods
increasing whole foods in your diet so i
totally agree with whole30 on that
however if i have a patient that's
having some sort of symptoms that
they're concerned about i wouldn't jump
to giving them a restrictive diet to
figure out if it's the result of food
sensitivities without doing some testing
first so my recommendation if you're
having some sort of weird symptoms going
on and you're considering whole30 pump
the brakes a little bit ask your doctor
talk to a registered dietitian is this
right for you have you checked
everything else that could be
contributing to your symptoms once you
do that and you have the all clear from
a registered health professional by all
means check it out let me know how it
goes whole30 isn't for everybody and
it's not perfect but there are certain
core principles within whole30 that are
absolutely ideal for everybody and i
think by following it learning a little
bit more about our own bodies that can
actually do some good so i'm a fan i
want to try whole30 myself for the next
month i'm gonna do exactly as it says
follow those eight principles and i'm
going to vlog along the way letting you
know how how my little journey is going
are you excited if you're excited
definitely let me know down below in the
comments if you have any outstanding
questions ask them down below as you
know i'm very active in the comments
section and if you want to check out a
really cool video click right here as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]